y
[Música]
hola bienvenidos esto es kobe 19 la
semana en américa el espacio de france
24 en el que hacemos un resumen de las
noticias más destacadas relacionadas con
la pandemia del cob y 19 hoy tendremos
un programa especial dedicado a la
región de centroamérica vamos a ver en
detalle la situación en panamá país en
donde hay un alto incremento en el
número de casos de contagio también
iremos a costa rica para conocer el
nuevo rumbo de la estrategia anti cobit
que adoptó el nuevo gobierno de ese país
en nicaragua hablaremos de las
diferencias en cuanto a las cifras de
contagio entre las autoridades y los
organismos internacionales mientras que
en honduras tendremos detalles de el
nuevo impulso al plan de vacunación y
hecho en ese país entretanto en el
salvador las autoridades han dicho que
la pandemia ya está por terminar pero en
que están pasando estas afirmaciones ya
lo vamos a ver y también analizamos
porque guatemala está rezagado en la
vacunación si lo comparamos con otros
países de américa latina
vamos a hacer entonces un repaso de
cifras vamos a ver entonces cómo están
los territorios de ultramar franceses en
el continente americano vamos a comenzar
en las islas de santiago y mikel o en
donde en los últimos 28 días han
reportado 202 casos y ningún fallecido
en el lado francés de la isla de san
martãn recordemos que esta isla también
tiene una parte neerlandesa hay 323
casos reportados en los últimos 28 días
pero tampoco hay víctimas mortales en la
barcina sanz barthélemy hay 179 casos y
0 fallecidos en guadalupe en donde la
crisis sanitaria golpeó con fuerza han
reportado más de 9 mil 943 casos en los
últimos 28 días pero ninguna muerte
hasta el momento martinica reporta más
de 5600 casos y también reporta cero
fallecidos vamos a terminar esta ronda
en guyana en suramérica en donde han
contabilizado más de 1.330 casos pero
solamente una persona fallecida
comenzamos a esta ronda en panamá país
en donde hay una alta vacunación pero
recientemente también han comenzado a
aumentar drásticamente los casos de
contagio vamos a conocer los detalles
con oscar sulbarán en ciudad de panamá
oscar gracias por acompañarnos hoy en el
programa y bueno qué es lo que está
sucediendo en panamá porque están
aumentando los casos de contagio
drásticamente
desde febrero no se reportaban en panamá
a más de tres mil casos de kobe 19 en un
día y durante esta semana por varios
días es ha sido la tendencia a 3.300
3500 casos la positividad ya ha superado
el 20 por ciento y las autoridades han
confirmado que el país se encuentra en
medio de una quinta ola de contagios
aunque también han manifestado que en
este momento no representa una amenaza
para la capacidad hospitalaria porque
por ejemplo de un poco más de 21.000
casos activos que hay en todo el país
casi la totalidad cumple su aislamiento
respectivo en sus hogares mientras que
menos de 200 de ese universo de 21 mil
contagiados se encuentran en hospitales
y de esos contagiados que están
hospitalizados sólo 10% está en cuidados
intensivos una cuarta parte de los casos
que se han reportado durante los últimos
días en panamá corresponden a la sub
variante de a punto 2 de omikron
oscar panamá es una economía muy
importante para la región que están
haciendo allí las autoridades para la
reactivación para fomentar un poco
también el emprendimiento y recuperar
esos dos años perdidos que dejó la
pandemia hasta el momento
recordemos que panamá en medio de la
pandemia registró una histórica caída de
su economía en 2020 después de
experimentar un crecimiento constante de
varios años el producto interno bruto se
contrajo en 17.9 % 2021 fue el año de la
recuperación creció 15.2 por ciento
coincidió precisamente con el inicio del
proceso de vacunación
ahora mismo panamá es uno de los países
de la región con mejor proyección de
crecimiento en 2022 sin embargo la
pandemia ha dejado a la economía con una
deuda mayor con un déficit fiscal que
pasó de 2.9 por ciento del producto
interno bruto a 5.5 por ciento el canal
de panamá la producción minera la
construcción han sido importantes para
la economía en panamá en esta etapa y
precisamente el área de la construcción
con la mano de la inversión pública es
una de las principales apuestas en los
planes del gobierno para reimpulsar la
economía
oscar mencionamos repunte de casos esto
se traduce entonces en la imposición de
restricciones o el gobierno ha
considerado simplemente empezar a
levantar las de una manera gradual y
cuál se mantiene
en pocas semanas se cumplirá en panamá
dos años del uso obligatorio de la
mascarilla si bien es cierto que desde
el pasado 28 de marzo se eliminó su
obligatoriedad en espacios abiertos
donde no existan en operaciones las
mascarillas siguen estando vigentes y es
una de las medidas que las personas
esperan que se quite del todo ante
repunte de los casos más que plantear o
tomar nuevas medidas el gobierno ha
hecho un llamado más al autocuidado a
mantener las medidas personales de
bioseguridad para frenar los contagios y
por otra parte a finales del medio abril
hubo un anuncio de la aplicación de una
cuarta dosis de la vacuna para personas
mayores de 12 años que sufran
enfermedades inmunosupresoras y también
de forma voluntaria para los mayores de
50 años
oscar muchas gracias por este reporte
desde ciudad de panamá vamos a ver más
números vamos a irnos entonces a conocer
el panorama general en la republica
dominicana el acumulado de casos en este
país llega ya a superar un poco más de
580 mil 200 casos desde el inicio de la
emergencia sanitaria hasta el día de hoy
han fallecido más de 4 mil 300 personas
el 54 49 por ciento de los dominicanos
ya tiene el esquema completo de
vacunación mientras que han sido
inoculadas
2129 dosis de refuerzo por cada 100
habitantes
continuamos en centroamérica vamos a
esta costa rica allí el cambio de
gobierno también significó un cambio en
el rumbo de la estrategia para combatir
el comil 19 muchas de las nuevas medidas
en recibieron críticas también algunas
terminaron confundiendo a los
costarricenses por eso vamos entonces
hasta san jose allí está sin regidor
para conocer más detalles indi gracias
por estar con nosotros en el programa
hoy y por favor porque fue tan
controvertido este cambio de la
estrategia de las políticas y que fue lo
que generó confusión entre los
ciudadanos
hola santiago si en efecto el primer
decreto anunciado por el presidente
rodrigo chávez ha sido criticado tanto
por cuestiones de forma como también de
fondo el colegio de médicos y cirujanos
por ejemplo dijo que la eliminación de
la obligatoriedad del uso de las
mascarillas resulta inoportuno cuando el
país registra un alza en los contagios
de coronavirus otras instituciones de
sociedad civil la iglesia católica y
evangélica han optado por recomendar que
se mantenga el uso de la mascarilla la
asamblea legislativa por su parte
mantiene vigente el acuerdo de uso
obligatorio de mascarilla dentro de sus
edificios epidemiólogos han dicho que el
momento epidemiológico actual no es el
idóneo para este cambio ya que la
cobertura de tres dosis de la vacuna
contra la cob y 19 es insuficiente y hay
indicios del inicio de una nueva ola el
presidente dijo que el decreto lo que
busca es darle la libertad y la
responsabilidad a la ciudadanía cindy es
interesante ver que algunas de las
críticas que recibió el gobierno fue por
haber retirado la obligatoriedad en
cuanto a la aplicación de las vacunas
luego tuvo que retractarse cómo manejar
en esta situación bueno sobre la
vacunación a la cob y 19 a pesar de que
chávez dijo el pasado 8 de mayo que el
decreto eliminaba la obligatoriedad
instaurada por el gobierno anterior una
vez que se publicó el contenido de ese
decreto se lee más bien como una
recomendación es decir solamente insta a
todas las instituciones públicas del
estado y al sector privado a no aplicar
sanciones de despido en los casos de
funcionarios que no cuentan con el
esquema de vacunación de kobe 19 para
abogados y especialistas en derecho
público la obligatoriedad no ha sido
eliminada en tanto que el actual
gobierno no derogó los decretos
anteriores que la instauraron lo que
chávez ha dicho es que su gobierno
respeta la autonomía de la voluntad de
los costarricenses que él recomienda a
las personas que se vacunen pero que
deben ser ellas quienes decidan aquí en
costa rica el 85% de la población se ha
aplicado una dosis el 80 por ciento 22 y
si sólo el 43 por ciento cuenta con una
tercera
cindy también fue levantada la
obligatoriedad en cuanto al uso de la
mascarilla cuál es el balance que hacen
las autoridades de esta medida y cómo lo
han recibido los ciudadanos
así es el otro decreto ya publicado en
el diario oficial elimina la
obligatoriedad del uso de mascarillas la
ministra de salud dijo que vigilarán el
comportamiento del virus y de haber
aumentos importantes en contagios y el
número de pacientes hospitalizados se
puede devolver al uso obligatorio de
mascarillas para proteger a la población
el decreto si contempla excepciones
sigue siendo obligatorio el uso de
tapabocas para todos los funcionarios de
salud de primera línea de atención del
sector público y privado y para las
personas cuando requieran acceder a los
establecimientos de salud del país la
mascarilla era requisito para ingresar a
supermercados a tiendas utilizar el
transporte público asistir a centros
educativos y centros de trabajo de
cualquier sector ahora en transporte
colectivo ya no es obligatorio mientras
que algunos centros educativos
restaurantes bares cines han dicho que
dejarán a sus clientes elegir el
ministerio de trabajo por su parte
informó que todos los centros de trabajo
tienen la potestad de establecer como
medida preventiva el uso obligatorio de
la mascarilla bien muchas gracias por
este reporte desde san jose vamos
regreso al caribe para ver cómo está la
situación en la isla de cuba el único
país de américa latina que desarrolló
sus propias vacunas para inocular a la
población vacunas de las que hemos
hablado a lo largo de este año aquí en
este programa el acumulado de casos de
cuba supera ya el millón 104 mil casos
desde que comenzó la pandemia unas 8500
personas han fallecido hasta el momento
en la isla de cuba la vacunación del
esquema completo ya supera el 87 punto
95 por ciento de la totalidad de la
población cubana es una de las cifras
más altas del continente mientras que el
porcentaje de dosis de refuerzo por cada
100 habitantes ya llega a
62,59 dosis también es uno de los más
altos de toda la región
y nicaragua ha sido un país muy
particular porque nunca declaró una
emergencia sanitaria y también el acceso
que ha tenido a las vacunas ha sido
bastante irregular y muy dependiente
sobre todo de la ayuda internacional
vamos a conversar con jorge hurtado
periodista nicaragüense que cubrió buena
parte de la pandemia estando allí en la
ciudad de managua y ahora está con
nosotros aquí en el estudio de france 24
jorge muchas gracias por acompañarnos
hoy en el programa y comienzo
preguntándole por ese informe de la ms
que dice que el ministerio de salud de
nicaragua estaría ocultando más de
11.000 muertes de nicaragüenses por kobe
19 el gobierno dice que solamente fueron
un poco más de
235 casos santiago y es que este dato de
la o ms solamente viene a confirmar al
de otros organismos de sociedad civil
que ya habían denunciado que las cifras
oficiales no coincidían con la realidad
de los fallecidos por 19 y aquí todo un
ejemplo el observatorio por la
transparencia entre corrupción de
colombia reveló a finales de 2021 que el
gobierno habría ocultado entre seis mil
y nueve mil muertes por cobit esto entre
2020 y 2021 varios médicos que hablaron
con los medios bajo anonimato aseguraron
que el gobierno intentó ocultar cifras
reales incluso si se compara a las
causas de muertes en el país antes de la
pandemia con 2020 2021 hay un gran
excedente de muertes por diversas causas
pero que según el gobierno ninguna de
ellas está asociadas con el cob y 19
otro organismo que denunció esto fue el
observatorio ciudadano un grupo
independiente de expertos que dieron
seguimiento a la pandemia en tiempo real
según este observatorio hasta hoy-
muertes asociadas con 19 hay seis mil en
el país aunque según la ms más de 12 mil
nicaragüenses murieron por el virus
porque ya lo mencionaba yo que dejar
agua tuvo un acceso bastante irregular a
las vacunas no compró directamente lotes
de vacunas para ellos tuvo que esperar
para recibirlas por parte de la
comunidad internacional que dicen
entonces allí como avanza el plan de
vacunación si es que hay algún plan de
vacunación en ese país centroamericano
bueno es que según el gobierno nicaragua
ha aplicado o ahí se han aplicado al
menos 10.4 millones de vacunas se
afirman que el 70 por ciento de la
población ha sido totalmente vacunado
aunque no han brindado detalles por
ejemplo de cuántas dosis de refuerzos
según la ope s los países con mayor
porcentaje de población vacunada en
centroamérica están costa rica primero
seguido de panamá y luego en tercer
lugar nicaragua al inicio entre la falta
de organización en la jornada de
nicaragua muchos ciudadanos cruzaron la
frontera para vacunarse en honduras y
jorge edad para terminar le pregunto
para su experiencia como ciudadano
nicaragüense cómo fue estar en un país
en el que no hubo un plan de acción no
hubo medidas restrictivas por parte del
gobierno ni medidas preventivas tampoco
todo recayó básicamente en las
decisiones que tomaban los ciudadanos
cómo fue vivir allí cuando el mundo
entero estaba confinado y con
restricciones bueno desde el inicio de
la pandemia este virus fue minimizado
por las autoridades incluso muchos
recuerdan una multitudinaria marcha que
ordenó el gobierno con todo el personal
médico del país en una especie de
carnaval para demostrar que todo estaba
bien pero la ciudadanía decidió
autoconvocarse para realizar su propio
confinamiento la empresa privada se sumó
a ese esfuerzo y fue cuando por casi
seis meses restaurantes cines centros
comerciales
la suspensión de actividades y mientras
la ciudadanía realizaba este auto
confinamiento el gobierno también
comenzó a convocar a sus partidarios a
miles de actividades religiosas
culturales y políticas como si el virus
no existiera un caso muy particular el
de nicaragua muchas gracias jorge por
habernos acompañado en el programa hoy a
continuación les presento más cifras más
números les presento el número de dosis
de refuerzo inoculadas por cada 100
habitantes en una serie de países al
azar vamos a comenzar por ejemplo en
mexico allí son 37 dosis que han sido
inoculadas por cada 100 habitantes
mientras tanto en colombia sólo 22 60
dosis han sido inoculadas por cada 100
habitantes estamos hablando de dosis de
refuerzo pasamos a perú en donde las
cifras ya sube considerablemente ya
llega el 50 50 dosis inoculadas por cada
100 habitantes en ese país muy cerca
también de esta argentina con 48 dosis y
finalizamos en brasil en donde alcanzan
43 dosis por cada 100 habitantes
continuamos con nuestra gira por
centroamérica nos vamos ahora hasta
honduras en donde el gobierno nacional
impulsó o impulsó mejor un plan nacional
de vacunación general entre el que
también está incluido por supuesto una
vacuna contra el joven 19 los detalles
los tiene quien ya torres desde
tegucigalpa hablamos con ella para
conocer más detalles kenia muchas
gracias por acompañarnos hoy y háblenos
entonces de esa jornada de vacunación
nacional que presidió la presidenta
castro
así es en santiago la misma presidenta
xiomara castró ha inaugurado esta
intensa jornada de vacunación que
concluirá este 31 de mayo la idea es
inocular a unos dos millones de
hondureños sobre todo a niños y jóvenes
que ya regresaron al sistema presencial
de clases aparte de la vigilancia de que
los hondureños cumplan con este esquema
completo de vacunación anti kobe de 19
pero en este proceso también se
aplicarán otro tipo de vacunas contra el
sarampión contra la polio contra la
difteria y además se tiene previsto
aplicarle a las mujeres embarazadas la
vacuna contra la influenza para cumplir
con este cometido se han instaurado 5000
y brigadas médicas que irán puerta a
puerta vacunando a todas estas personas
el costo aproximado es de un millón y
medio de dólares gastos que están siendo
sufragados por el gobierno de castro es
importante señalar que a nivel de la
organización mundial de la salud
honduras ha recibido muchas
felicitaciones por su efectivo sistema
de vacunación contra enfermedades como
la difteria por ejemplo en este año se
celebran 32 años sin que exista un solo
caso de esta enfermedad
31 años de no tener ni un solo caso de
poliomielitis y 26 años sin sarampión
pero el principal objetivo en este
momento también es empezar con la
erradicación del 19 que ha dejado más de
10 mil hondureños fallecidos si tenía
quería preguntarle precisamente por las
vacunas porque honduras ha tenido acceso
a diferentes lotes recientemente recibió
uno a través de él kóvacs donado por
eeuu de cuántas dosis estamos hablando
efectivamente este donativo de 250 mil
trescientos ochenta
vacunas a facer que ha hecho estados
unidos en la segunda asignación que le
corresponde a honduras con el mecanismo
cobas la primera asignación de este 2022
se hizo recién en el mes de marzo y ahí
honduras recibió casi 400.000 vacunas de
esta misma casa farmacéutica
cabe señalar que a pesar que en este
momento en el país hay vacunas de los 5
millones de hondureños elegibles sólo 3
millones se aplicó por lo menos la
primera dosis pero no se ha completado
por ejemplo la segunda dosis de vacunas
menos la tercera por eso el gobierno y
la secretaria de salud han intensificado
las campañas de concientización
invitando a la gente a que complete
estos este esquemas de vacunación
ahora que el mismo gobierno ha ordenado
la reactivación de las clases
presenciales en escuelas colegios y
universidades
es importante señalar también que eeuu a
través de este mecanismo kóvacs ha sido
el principal donante de vacunas para
honduras de los más de 5 millones de
lotes que han ingresado al país eeuu ha
donado casi
4.5 millones de vacunas en este momento
la curva de contagios ha descendido
ostensiblemente en la última semana sólo
se reportaron 11 contagios y ya se
deshabilitaron los diferentes centros de
acopio para enfermos y para la
aplicación de pruebas anti kobe que el
gobierno habían instalado en las
principales ciudades del país
y hablemos ahora de las restricciones
hay en honduras cuales se mantienen
cuáles han sido levantadas por parte de
las autoridades
a estas alturas podemos decir que el
país se prácticamente ha retornado a la
normalidad y es que este es un paso que
se tuvo que dar de manera acelerada el
año anterior a pesar de que los picos de
contagio de comida 19 estaban en lo más
alto porque honduras recién reabría su
economía cuando sufrió el embate de dos
huracanes eta y otan que acabaron en
prácticamente con el 80 por ciento de
los cultivos de productos agrícolas de
palma africana de café de banano que son
los principales productos de exportación
del país entonces a la parte de la
reconstrucción se dio la reapertura para
el caso de aeropuertos de las fronteras
de los centros comerciales de las
actividades de las pequeñas empresas
también se abrieron los escenarios
deportivos
recién les comentaba que hace un mes la
presidenta acción mar a castro ordenó el
retorno a clases presenciales de más de
2 millones de niños que todavía se
mantenían con el esquema de clases
virtuales la única medida que se
mantiene vigente hasta este momento y
que es de estricto cumplimiento es el
uso de la mascarilla en todas y todos
los comercios también en los aeropuertos
en las escuelas en los colegios en las
universidades es obligatorio el uso de
la mascarilla desde que se conoció un
primer contagio aquí en honduras de kobe
19 según las autoridades de salud casi
500 mil hondureños se han contagiado y
diez mil
896 han fallecido por la pandemia
tenía muchas gracias por este completo
informe desde tegucigalpa
y en el vecino el salvador la alta tasa
de vacunación y también la baja
incidencia de casos llevó a que las
autoridades afirmara que la pandemia y
la emergencia está por finalizar qué
tanta razón tendrán vladimir chamorro
desde sant salvador nos va a contar la
de mil gracias por acompañarnos hoy en
el programa bueno ya lo decíamos varios
días consecutivos sin presentar
fallecidos por kobe 19 y ya salió el
ministro de salud salvadoreño a decir
que la emergencia está prácticamente a
punto de terminar pueden cantar victoria
y en el salvador
hola santiago así es el ministerio de
salud ha informado de un marcado
descenso en la letalidad del coronavirus
este mes según registros oficiales se
acumulan más de 10 días sin decesos por
la mortal enfermedad
francisco a la vie ministro de salud
celebró este hecho asegurando además que
en el país la pandemia está bajo control
manteniendo los casos de contagio en el
mínimo incluso ha afirmado que la
pandemia ya está por finalizar de
acuerdo con datos del gobierno el
salvador únicamente acumula poco más de
4000 fallecidos desde el inicio de la
pandemia sin embargo las cifras
oficiales han sido cuestionadas por la
organización mundial de la salud y otros
organismos internacionales que señalan
la existencia de un subregistro que
podría alcanzar hasta 4 muertes por
comida no registradas por cada deceso a
causa del virus registrados por el
gobierno
vladimir lo reportamos en este programa
que allí en el salvador han levantado
varias restricciones que había impuesto
el gobierno cuál es el balance que hacen
las autoridades después de haberlas
levantadas
el salvador ha levantado prácticamente
todas las restricciones para contener el
avance de el coronavirus la última
medida en esa línea fue dejar de exigir
el uso obligatorio de mascarilla a
finales de abril aunque las autoridades
siguen recomendando a la población que
las lleve puestas como una precaución
ante la enfermedad ya en noviembre
pasado se habían eliminado los
requisitos sanitarios de ingreso al
territorio nacional como la presentación
de pruebas negativas y cartillas de
vacunación para viajeros extranjeros y
nacionales por otra parte desde que
inició el periodo de reapertura el país
ha mostrado un ritmo estable de
recuperación económica ganando el
terreno que había perdido tras la
pandemia lo anterior contribuyó a la
recuperación de muchos de los casi 70
mil empleos que se perdieron durante la
cuarentena estricta según cifras
oficiales la ddi mira hablemos ahora del
plan de vacunación porque el salvador
junto a costa rica y panamá eran algunos
de los países líderes de la región como
está avanzando la vacunación allí
el salvador necesitaría alrededor de 6
millones de dosis para cubrir a los
habilitados para vacunarse lo que
costaría unos 86 millones de dólares
según un reciente estudio del instituto
centroamericano de estudios fiscales
icefi el país ya tiene a disposición la
cuarta dosis de la vacuna anti kobe la
cual ha sido administrada a un
aproximado de 200.000 personas mientras
que la primera y segunda dosis han sido
recibidas por poco más de 4 millones de
habitantes y la tercera únicamente por
16 millones en ese sentido el informe
advierte la desaceleración en la
aplicación de dosis lo que podría
representar un año más para completar la
meta de vacunación pese a que la
cobertura de la segunda dosis llego al
70% de la población hasta el primer
trimestre de 2022 él dice que señaló que
el salvador fue el país de centroamérica
donde menos creció la cobertura de las 2
dosis de la vacuna según expertos en la
materia esto podría deberse a la
introducción prematura de la tercera
dosis generalizada en septiembre del
2021 sin haber alcanzado una aceptable
de la segunda dosis la de mil muchas
gracias por este reporte desde la ciudad
de san salvador vamos a salirnos un poco
de centroamérica y vamos a ver algunas
noticias también destacadas de esta
semana por ejemplo algunos medios de
comunicación de los eeuu como el
prestigioso medio forms han declarado a
la ciudad de sao paulo la capital
mundial de las vacunas la metrópolis
brasileña con más de 12 millones de
habitantes tiene el 100 por ciento de su
población adulta totalmente vacunada los
corresponsales de france 24 fueron hasta
esta ciudad que es la más grande y
también la más poblada de américa latina
para descubrir cuál es el secreto del
éxito sanitario en un país que supera ya
los
664 mil fallecidos por cubrir 19
san paolo es la ciudad de brasil que
concentró más muertes por el coronavirus
son más de 42 mil fallecimientos en poco
más de dos años de pandemia
gracias a una intensa campaña de
vacunación la ciudad que llegó a superar
a nueva york y ciudad de méjico y número
de muertos
hoy respira aliviada eufic elaborado
curso yo me he quedado pasmada con sao
paulo porque a pesar de ser una ciudad
monstruosa la organización y la agilidad
para mí en relación a río de janeiro
está perfecta
roxana cuenta que en río de janeiro
donde nació hay muchas filas para la
vacuna ancianos y jóvenes son obligados
a compartir el mismo espacio en san
paolo todo le resulta más organizado se
incluye siempre la
esta fonoaudióloga ya recibió las tres
dosis de vacuna contra él comí 19 muchas
gracias de nada hoy le toca la vacuna
contra la gripe imprescindible para
quien trabaja en el campo de la salud
todos los habitantes de san paulo ya
completaron el protocolo de inmunización
contra el coronavirus esto explica la
baja afluencia a este centro de
vacunación
ya tuvimos una adhesión muy grande y
mucho movimiento hoy estamos en la
cuarta dosis hay mucho menos personas
gracias a dios estamos teniendo un
proceso de vacunación muy amplios s
sebastián la vena amp la enorme
capilaridad de los centros sanitarios
fue clave y permitió vacunar a muchas
personas al mismo tiempo
nos tenemos la ciudad de sao paulo 470
mil acciones aparte tenemos 470 centros
de salud como decía linda estas unidades
los fabricamos
y además creamos otros 700 puestos de
vacunación cuando recibimos las dosis
del ministerio de sanción al ministerio
de salud además la policía ayudó a
despejar las calles para que las dosis
de vacuna pudiesen circular rápidamente
por esta metrópolis casi siempre
colapsada por el tráfico
gracias a dios'
de fascinación
gracias adiós con un alto índice de
vacunación la población ahora tiene la
posibilidad de retomar la normalidad y
los indicadores económicos van a
demostrar que por cierto y positivo
seguir la ciencia que siguió orientación
de acs todo un éxito a pesar del
presidente de jair bolsonaro que
boicoteó la vacuna china importada por
el gobernador de sao paulo y llegó a
decir que podría convertir a las
personas en caimanes
volvemos a centroamérica guatemala es el
país con la tasa de vacunación más baja
de toda américa latina vamos a hablar
entonces con andrés suárez para conocer
detalles de que lo que está pasando allí
andrés gracias por acompañarnos en esta
oportunidad desde antigua guatemala y
cuéntenos cuál es el panorama general de
este país centroamericano adelante
hola santiago un gusto bueno justamente
aquí en su programa reportamos a
comienzos de año la nueva ola de
contagios de kobe 19 en guatemala pero a
estas alturas del 2022 específicamente
en mayo se puede ver cuán relajado está
el panorama en materia de salud en el
más reciente informe presentado por el
ministerio de salud guatemalteco queda
expuesto que tan solo 14 de los 340
municipios del país se encuentran en
alerta roja esto quiere decir que en
estos 14 municipios que representan
menos del 5% de la población se debe
usar obligatoriamente el tapabocas y las
otras medidas de contención como lavado
de manos y distanciamiento social el
resto de municipios que corresponden al
otro 95% por ejemplo aquí en antigua
están clasificados en alerta amarilla o
alerta naranja en donde no se hace
obligatorio el uso del tapabocas tan
sólo se sugiere que se siga aportando
esto en un país que a la fecha acumula
ochocientos cuarenta y cinco mil casos
de kobe 19
andrés ya usted nos dice se mantiene la
alerta roja en varios municipios pero
hay un rezago de dos años en la
vacunación en la inoculación del plan
básico de vacunación un poco más del 30
por ciento de los guatemaltecos tienen
el esquema completo como avanza entonces
el plan allí
santiago efectivamente guatemala es uno
de los países que señalados por tener
las más bajas tasas de vacunación de
américa porque mientras naciones como
eeuu dinamarca españa han logrado
mitigar la pandemia gracias a esquemas
de vacunación completos entre el 66 y el
83 por ciento de su población en
guatemala el panorama es desolador aquí
solamente se ha podido vacunar con
esquema completo de primera y segunda
dosis a un 34 por ciento de la población
esto está muy por debajo de lo
recomendado por la organización mundial
de la salud la oms de que para que una
nación pueda regresar retornar a la
normalidad debería haber por lo menos
vacunado al 70 por ciento de la
población en ese sentido en guatemala se
han administrado 17 millones de dosis de
vacunas de las cuales sólo 6 millones
han sido de esquema completo y la
población más vulnerable que más
desamparada y que menos vacuna ha estado
frente a esta pandemia son los niños de
entre 6 y 11 años andrés efectivamente
hay muchos problemas en cuanto al
desarrollo del plan de vacunación
incluso hay denuncia de vencimiento de
los otros completos de vacunas que ha
recibido guatemala que dicen las
autoridades sobre esto
el vencimiento de las vacunas ha sido
otro de los lunares de un plan nacional
de vacunación tardío aquí en guatemala
con respecto a otros países de la región
aquí se comenzó a vacunar hace 13 meses
poco más de un año y conforme no se han
desplegado planes de vacunación masivos
se han comenzado a vencer grandes
cantidades de lotes de vacunas en este
2022 el caso más escandaloso es el de la
vacuna sputnik la russa un 62% de las
dosis que guatemala le compró a rusia se
han desperdiciado esto corresponde a 4
millones de vacunas porque los
guatemaltecos han preferido vacunarse
con facer con modernas y han rechazado
la vacuna rusa pero esto representa una
pérdida de 40 millones de dólares y
compromete seriamente la administración
del actual mandatario alejandro
giammatei con respecto a la pandemia de
kobe 19
andrés muchas gracias por este reporte
desde antigua en guatemala vamos con
otras las noticias destacadas a nivel
internacional porque esta semana corea
del norte anunció su primera víctima
mortal por kobe 19 una cifra que ya
aumentó a 6 y se espera aumente con el
paso de los días según las autoridades
el virus ya se ha extendido por todo el
país miles de personas están actualmente
aisladas o están ya recibiendo
tratamiento se está llevando a cabo
también un bloqueo nacional ante el
temor de que la infección generalizada
pueda provocar una escasez masiva de
alimentos en ese país asiático
kim jong-un visitó la sede nacional de
prevención de epidemias en corea del
norte a primera hora del jueves según
los medios estatales el líder del país
se reunió con integrantes del partido
del trabajo para hablar del brote de
kobe 19 en el país
su respuesta declarar el estado de
emergencia más severo y anunciar un
confinamiento nacional según los medios
de comunicación estatales varias
personas murieron y miles enfermaron con
fiebre y reconocieron que uno de los
fallecidos fue contagiado por la
variante omicron según la agencia
oficial de noticias
350.000 personas han sido tratadas por
fiebre desde finales de abril más de
180.000 norcoreanos están actualmente
aislados y en tratamiento aunque no se
ha especificado cuántos positivos por
kobe 19 hay se cree que la mayoría de
los 26 millones de habitantes del país
no están vacunados corea del norte
rechazó las ofertas de vacunación de la
ms pero también de china y rúsia los
expertos dicen que un brote podría ser
una catástrofe
debido al 19 la escasez de alimentos y
la crisis económica podrían deteriorarse
en corea del norte para evitarlo corea
del norte está llevando a cabo medidas
de racionamiento de alimentos así que
están bajo medidas de cuarentena muy
severas para prevenir un brote masivo de
casos confirmados de kobe según los
expertos el virus llegó a corea del
norte a través de una persona que cruzó
la frontera ilegalmente desde china y
demos un vistazo a otras noticias
relacionadas con la pandemia que están
destacadas en redes el diario 'el país'
titula la oms se calcula en más del
doble el registro oficial del número de
muertes por la pandemia en mexico según
la investigación el exceso de mortalidad
por el kobe 19 asciende a 626 mil
fallecidos esta cifra es dos veces mayor
que la casi de 300 mil decesos que
arrojan los datos oficiales que fueron
entregados en diciembre por las
autoridades mexicanas y la organización
mundial del turismo reconoce a república
dominicana por su ejemplar recuperación
turística el organismo destacó la
gobernanza y también el liderazgo para
levantar la industria turística que es
la principal fuente de divisas en ese
país caribeño también destacó que
república dominicana tiene un amplio
liderazgo en el desarrollo de turismo
sostenible y vamos a terminar en
colombia con nueva planta colombia busca
producir 160 millones de vacunas al año
la farmacéutica sinovac construirá una
nueva planta de producción de vacunas en
la ciudad de bogotá la capital del país
que se suma a otra planta que está
siendo construida por parte de la
farmacéutica baxter que está ubicada en
cercanías de la ciudad de medellín
y así llegamos al final de kobe 19 la
semana en américa sigan cuidándose en la
emergencia persiste y también sigan
viendo france24 nos vemos la próxima
semana hasta entonces
[Música]